when you look at the IDM cloud strategy
we really have a spectrum of
capabilities because we can support
clients that want to do many things some
clients want to have bare metal they
want to take their application their
environment they want to run it on bare
metal and have total control and really
what they're looking for is they're just
looking for the infrastructure that we
can provide them other clients they want
to run on the public cloud and they want
all of the economics that come along
with running on the public cloud instead
of them having to build and buy all of
the infrastructure that they need to run
their business there are other clients
that want to connect and the notion of
hybrid comes in I've got a new mobile
application and I want to connect my
mobile application to my back end
transaction system maybe I want data
from my inventory system maybe I want
access to my bank account or to be able
to do a banking transaction and then
there's other clients that want to build
private clouds they understand the
inherent efficiency of building a
private cloud but maybe for regulatory
reasons or for data locality sovereignty
reasons they have to have the data in
their data center but they want to be
able to run a private cloud we're really
the only provider that provides
everything from the public all the way
to the private and we can pull it
together in ways that others cannot and
we can help clients bridge that
transformation and for the enterprise
they don't have the ability to start
over again they have to integrate with
the trillions of dollars of investments
that they've made in their IT systems
but we want to enable them to move
forward and move forward at the speed of
the cloud and we're well positioned to
be able to provide that through
softlayer CMS bluemix all the way up
through our software as a service so we
really do have the broadest set of
capability in the market
when you think about IBM Cloudant
there's a couple advantages that we can
bring for the enterprise and one of them
is at the hybrid nature because you know
whether you're building an application
is going out in mobile or you're trying
to build the next generation of
inventory management system you really
want to be able to connect the data the
business process is all your business
logic that you've got in your
traditional systems or what we call
systems of record to your new systems of
engagement no systems of engagement of
things like mobile and all of the social
you want to be able to take all of that
social information that's out there
combine it with the data that you have
in premise and really come up with maybe
a new way or new approach or a new
product or service that you want to
bring to the market as an example
Millennials love the fact that you can
mark it to me as an individual you know
what I like you look at my social data
and you say wow I really like this
product or service and here's an offer
for that product or service that's
really getting to be a personalized
experience as a consumer and all that's
being enabled by social by mobile and by
the cloud earlier this year we formed a
cloud unit and the reason we put all of
these pieces together and put a team
together we have to move with speed the
world is moving very very quickly and
we're in what I call the second phase of
the cloud and the second phase of the
cloud is all around the use of data and
analytics and really around business
transformation how do i transform the
processes that drive my business how do
i transform the processes that my end
user whether it be an employee or a
consumer or a client is going to use we
really do have a great understanding of
what is the next generation of the cloud
and we are going to have to move with
speed there's a lot of innovation that's
going on out there some of it will come
from IBM some of it will come from the
market and our ability to pull it all
together and help clients is going to be
a huge advantage so if I was to say
there's one thing we've got to do well
we've got to execute on our strategy and
do it with extreme speed
I think the cloud is bringing a set of
capabilities that enables everyone and
anyone to play I have more access now to
people around the world think about our
access through our social networks I
have more access to data than I ever
have before I've got data not only the
company's gather but things like Twitter
and the weather channel I have more data
that i can analyze than ever before and
I've got the ability to bring others
into my ecosystem so before I'd have to
come up with the idea in my own company
now I can come up with the idea in the
large think about what we do with
hackathons and how we get a lot of smart
people together and they come up with
new ideas so now I don't have to spend
all of my own money on building up the
infrastructure the infrastructure is out
there in the cloud so I get access to
great ideas I get access to resources I
get access to data I get access to
people and when you start to make access
that easy and ubiquitous great ideas
great inventions and things that can
change the world will happen